hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to five nights at freddy's
an indie horror game that you guys
suggested in mass and i saw that yami
mass played and he said it was really
really good so i'm very eager to see
what is up and that is a terrifying
animatronic bear family pizzeria looking
for a security guard to work the night
shift
oh
12 a.m the first night if i didn't want
to stay the first night why would i stay
any more than five why would i stay any
more than do hello
okay
hello
hello oh
oh i can't move
that's a creepy skull
it's creepy things on the wall
oh hello
hello
hi hello hi uh i wanted to record a
message for you
to help you get settled in on your first
night
um i actually worked in that office
before you
finishing up my last week now as a
matter of fact so
i know it can be a bit overwhelming
but i'm going to tell you there's
nothing to worry about
you'll be fine
so let's just focus on getting you
through your first video okay
uh let's see first there's an
introductory greeting from the company
that i'm supposed to read
it's kind of a legal thing you know
um to freddy fazbear's pizza okay a
magical place for kids and grown-ups
alike where fantasy and fun come to life
as for entertainment is not responsible
for damage to property or person upon
discovering that damage or death has
occurred a missing person report will be
filed within 90 days where as soon as
property and premises have been
thoroughly cleaned and bleached and the
carpets have been replaced blah blah
blah now that might sound bad i know but
there's really nothing to worry about
uh the animatronic characters here do
get a bit quirky at night but do i blame
them
if i were forced to sing those same
stupid songs for 20 years and i never
got about i'd probably be a bit
irritable at night too so remember these
characters hold a special place in the
hearts of children and you need to show
them a little respect okay okay okay so
just be aware the characters do tend to
wander
but then there was the bite of 87. the
bite yeah
what brain it's amazing that the human
body can live without the frontal lobe
why
now concerning your safety the only real
risk to you as a night watchman here if
any is the fact that these characters
if they happen to see you after hours
probably won't recognize you as a person
they'll most likely see you as a middle
endo skeleton without its costume
now since that's against the rules here
at freddy fazbear's pizza they'll
probably try to
forcefully stuff you inside a freddy
fazbear's suit oh i get it um
now that wouldn't be so bad if the suits
themselves weren't filled with cross
beams wired and animatronic devices
especially around the facial area so you
can imagine having your head forced to
be pressed inside one of those could
cause a bit of discomfort
the only parts of you that would like to
see the light of day again would be your
eyeballs and teeth pop out the front of
the mask
they don't tell you these things
but hey first stationary breeze i'll
chat with you tomorrow
uh check those cameras and remember to
close the doors only if absolutely
necessary it's not good
all right good night
good night
oh no
oh that's bad i understand what i need
to do i need to watch the cam so that
they don't come after me what's amazing
oh hi
there you are
pretty bunny thing
okay
okay i get it i get it i get it where'd
you go you're still there all right you
stay there
i don't know if it's good that you're
staring at me oh my god
i thought it was weird that it couldn't
move this is totally different
than any horror game i've ever played so
what you got to do in case you're not
getting it is you got to watch the
cameras to make sure
they don't come by and you only got a
little much power
is he still there hi you're still there
wait a minute what did you move okay you
didn't move
you don't move neither
you don't move an oven
see you moving i don't want to see
anything
oh my god
that's terrifying
why do i leave the doors open why isn't
there enough power hi okay you moved
again
hi
what are you doing there
might be getting a little close to me
oh oh oh no oh no no no no no no
no no no no
you're gonna get me okay you're over
there all right
it's okay
why can't i even have enough power for
lights
stay right there you douchebag
you stay right there there
god damn it
that is like this is like the most
terrifying game i've ever played
they're gonna pop out of me oh god he's
gone hi okay
you're just gonna alternate between the
two places it's totally fine
you're the friends
they ain't moving
i see where i am
you're not near me so that's good i'm
just gonna periodically check
how much longer do i need i need to last
till 6am
oh god am i going to have enough power
oh my god if i run out of power will
they be like
stay right there
why am i still using some power
oh
god
seriously i have one this is like
this is like
bad
you're still there okay this is the
first night they said it should be easy
the first night so i'm only assuming one
of them
is going to be wandering around and it's
just a creepy bunny guy
happy fun time at freddy's fun land
having such a wonderful time
still there okay we're still there i'm
gonna name you
bunny ball
today oh god where'd he go oh god this
is here
oh
where'd he go
hi again okay you stay right there there
i don't want to have to deal yo
probably shouldn't do that i need to
conserve power
god damn it i was like half the damn
thing i think the doors were down
still there
okay
i hear that
oh god
where's the other one
where is he
where are they
where'd he go where'd he go where'd he
go where are both of them hi you're
really close to me
oh god it's not 6am yet hi
okay
so i think i just need to keep the left
door closed
no where'd he go
oh hi hi hi hi hi okay okay i don't have
much power left what are you gonna do
was the other one still there
hi
oh you moved again
what do i do what do i do oh
you're still right behind the door
oh what happens if i open the door
i'm gonna run out of power
oh is he there
[Music]
no
hi oh god dammit
how are you doing
[Music]
[Applause]
oh god not again why would i do this
stupid job
okay
so i ran out of power
but
oh hi hi again do you have any sage
advice for me
yep okay yep i know yep yep yup yup what
can i do for you
i know
oh god uh hello hello
uh well if you're hearing this and you
made it today too
congrats
i won't talk quite as long this time
since freddie and his friends tend to
become more active if the week
progresses
uh it might be a good idea to peek at
those cameras while i talk just to make
sure everyone's in their proper place no
interestingly enough freddie himself
doesn't come on stage very often
i've heard he becomes a lot more active
in the dark though so hey
i guess that's one more reason not to
run out of power right i also want to
emphasize the importance of using your
door lights
there are blind spots in your camera
view and those blind spots happen to be
right outside your doors so if you can't
find something or someone on your
cameras
check the door light
you might only have a few seconds to
react
but not that you would be in any danger
of course i'm not applying that
anyway i'm sure you have everything
under control uh talk to you soon
where's pirate cove why are you gonna
leave me with this
don't leave me like this where's where's
big yellow there's big yellow is he
still there
yes you're still there
very good
oh
don't lie
there
okay
we're okay
we're gonna be fine
we're gonna be totally fine
we're gonna be fine hello hello bubsy
where's the other guy where's the other
guy
where is he
where's he where is he where is he where
is he where oh there okay
he's not the eye
hey freddie
how are you doing
okay
you gonna be nearby
stay there where's the other one where's
the other one where's the other one
there he is okay i am panic i am losing
my [ __ ] right now
i'm not okay with this oh god not again
no no no
don't you beat the oh god
hey he's right outside
okay
god this night is lasting forever
that's not okay
okay so once my high
let's eat let's eat wine are you still
there okay he's gone
good
stay gone forever never and ever and
ever oh you're coming back
either that or you're leaving
oh i'm not going to have enough
my butt is going to be munched i'm going
to be shoved into a teddy bear outfit
and they're going to laugh
where is he where'd he go
that buddy wants to get my giblets
but you can't have them
not today
whatever
good thing freddy's staying in his house
hi mr wait bunny you were just outside
my door
where's the ducky
where's mr zement no no ducky there
i
hear
hi mr ducky
god this night is lasting so long
i just want to go home
i never want to play this game again
i'll be a good boy
god damn it this would be like
terrifying if you controlled the cameras
with like an oculus rift or something
oh my god because you just move your
head back and forth
oh my god hi again where's the other one
there you go where'd he go oh there he
is okay as long as you too stay right
there
you gotta be good you look very pretty
where was the pirate cove guy oh here is
pirate cove okay so i just gotta
keep an eye on you guys
gonna be fine
oh i i bet using the camera takes power
too i'm down to 34
i got three hours to go
no
you're still there you're still there
you're still there
you're looking at me now
hi pirate code man
oh where'd they go
still there
marco man
are you done
oh man i love working at disney world
it's my favorite
hi what are you doing out here
please get back in i don't want you out
of here
please cup is for me
oh he's coming for me
oh why do i have to watch three of them
i'm like legit freaking out right now
i'm not okay with this
oh god they moved
you moved to oh you're coming down the
hallway huh which one are you
and i left pirate cove yet you're still
there coming down that hallway
parago man
how are you doing firecoat man
no
i got two hours left
no no no
no
what's that sound oh he's right there
well
he's not here just yet
i don't want to run out of power
oh the sounds i don't like them
perfect no oh yeah i am [ __ ] [ __ ]
i tried to push it
oh my god
oh
oh game over indeed
oh those my
oh eyeballs
okay
so that was five nights at freddy's i
couldn't even survive two god damn it
oh
god
oh i tried to hit the door i tried so
bad
oh
okay
okay thank you all so much for watching
check out the other scary games that i
played and if you want to play this for
yourself you could check it in the
description below if you really want me
to play it again and try to beat it
let me know in the comments below thanks
again everybody and as always i will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
okay